so what was it like falling in love with
this man on camera life-changing I do
know what it was so easy yeah it was so
easy you know it's something that
expanded me it was just like to be in
something with someone and their heart
is wide open and your heart is wide open
and you are making something it's like
I've been searching forever so it's
awkward enough or hard enough sometimes
for people to just kind of like meet
like if they if they're having a dinner
order like that first scene that you
guys do but like you guys get so close
you're in that car together for so long
that scene that you do the love scene
that you do like was it a challenge to
do then you said it was easy for you to
fall in love with him what like to get
to get that close that intimate with
someone so quickly
I think we I think we had I think Jody
there's the one that kind of mentioned
this about how she wanted the the love
scene to be sensual and have a real
sensual language and um and kind of and
then we sat down and talked about the
storytelling and understood like what we
tried to say because this is not just a
sexiness is a scene yeah and the sex is
the language of that scene and so like
are we trying to say to each other and
it's kind of like it's almost like the
inverse of the dynasty Jones saying this
like there's a back and forth or
something now if you realized the other
day the diner scene there is the
connection it's just negative one just
saying there's a Jimena but they don't
even realize they they have that
connection because they're so they're in
their own spaces and this is when they
they create the new United space mmm and
I think that's kind of was really
excited to create yeah Lena is so
passionate about this story um I want to
know when you knew and when you knew
like this is something I got to be a
part of um when I first read it yeah I
first read it I was like I want to watch
this film mmm I just want to watch it so
if I'm a part of it amazing if I'm not
amazing like
this gaming like Johnson is like it's
just like I think that's what was is the
humanity in both characters the richness
in all this the supporting roles they
were like fully formed human beings with
all their attitudes and how they
impacted the the the main love story is
there's so much heart that's and soul
that's in this and I'm when I read that
just was like I need to yeah when I read
about it you know because by the time
obviously they've generated way back and
then I mean I read about it in first saw
that it was liking at this project that
Daniel who you was hatched you and I had
so much respect for him as an actor and
I was certain I was like very interested
and I was also producing the fact that
he was also executive producing it I'm
like okay and then Lina with having
written it and then Molina being the
director and so I reached out to my team
and I was like what is this how can I
get my hands on this and when I read the
project when I read the script I was
just like I was completely blown away by
the story about this woman queen and and
I just at that point was like okay I'm
desperate to be about it
but I did I do remember having that
thought that I was like whether or not I
get to be in this film I wanted to see
this film yeah
the accolades for this are already
coming in accolades for both of you are
already coming in what does that mean to
you does it mean anything to you that
people say you're fantastic in this
you're amazing in this I will accolades
Ivan Ivanych last night so I don't know
anything but I'm man like I think you
can't get too attached to any of that
stuff and I try my hardest to have a
mind frame when I'm working I'm not
trying to be good I'm not trying to be
bad I'm trying to be honest yeah and I'm
just trying to tell truth and go home
John saying it's like and then whatever
everyone believes in that if you have a
negative a positive opinion it's true
even like actually actually I do that to
protect myself from myself because
sometimes I rip myself to shreds when I
watch myself and I go that's how I feel
that day John saying that's that's where
I was at yeah Jose Annan did go
obviously I would do it different now
cuz he is gone by yeah
Rack is a year later so it's just it
just relieves you from a lot of the
turmoil that like creating stuff comes
in Johnson and so it's amazing that like
they singular now people but they're
what makes this so special is this is a
team of things this is the United force
that came together and and to tell the
story for really great reasons yeah and
this for me it was cool yeah yeah I'm
just excited that people are feeling
moved by the movie yeah I mean that was
really cool it's my first time ever
experiencing dude something like that
worth having any you know the kind of
feedback for people to like we loved
this this was you know this meant
something to me
so to just like be inside of that with
everyone it's like really really amazing
I mean last night it's like I couldn't
even even get to each other at the
summer mommy's calmer but it's cool
because it was just everyone was just
like swarmed with love that it feels
cool to be a part like I'm just so
honored and like humbled to be a part
because like nothing in this film could
have worked without the commitment from
everybody who was involved in such a way
it was like it was so important to all
of us and to be a part of something
where it's so important everyone yeah
that is so powerful and it's
life-changing you know it changed my
life amazing it's beautiful thank you so
much guys thank you for that soon thank
you thank you I appreciate you ready to
meet you
you